like sagitt apparently has missed all
those statements so hopefully he will
take note of what I'm saying in this
video so that he can stop
misrepresenting me in the future
I've come together with the one on my
charity this winter bone sisters helped
to feed those who are in poor conditions
and who don't even have a clothing to
keep theirself warm your small donation
might mean nothing to you but it can
change their life and help them survive
the winter this year
do not rebel against the ruler Muslim
skeptic says do not rebel against the
ruler the Mercury say you should obey
the ruler Muslim skeptic says you should
obey the ruler the Mercury advise the
ruler in private Muslim skeptic says yes
advise the ruler in private if possible
but if it's not possible then it's
permissible to do it publicly in order
to serve the greater good that's it
that's the only difference that is
causing these metallis to denounce us as
deviance and declare that we are hoarage
dogs of Hellfire and that our blood is
haral and that is really what it means
to be a bootlicker that is what I am
referring to when I use the term
bootlicker a bootlicker is not someone
who says don't do or don't do takfir or
don't disobey the ruler that's not what
makes someone a bootlecker because all
of those positions are represented in
the scholarly tradition a bootlegger on
the other hand says don't you dare ever
do um
against the ruler publicly don't you
dare shut your mouth no matter what kind
of evil the ruler does
sorry Alfie you are a bootlegger and
there is no one from the salaf who share
your deviated view yes there were salaf
who remained silent in the face of the
monkure of the ruler and other salaf who
loudly and openly denounced the ruler
for that monkey but the first group
never told the second group to shut up
shut your mouth the setup were not
Bootleggers like you when we look at the
Quran the Sunnah the statements of the
salaf the statements of the khalaf and
the fatawa of the senior odama past and
present there is so much evidence that
agrees with our position and contradicts
the view of the metralies and
bootleggers
now there's one other loose end that we
should address in his video search it
implies that I have made blanket Tech
fear against rulers as proof of this he
takes two separate statements I have
made in separate contexts and he brings
these statements together as proof that
I'm doing blanket Tech fear and inciting
Rebellion against Muslim rulers the
first statement I have made is that no
Muslim country today fully applies
Sharia the second statement is that not
ruling by the Sharia makes one a cafe
Sajid combines these two statements to
claim that I am making blanket takvir on
all rulers today but this is not fair I
made each of these statements in a
particular context and I have never made
the blanket take fear that Sajid is
accusing me of making as for the
statement that no country applies Sharia
100 that's obviously true and I dare
saja to deny it sadly Muslim countries
have been ravished by colonialism and
Military pressure applied by Western
States for that reason such societies do
not and are not permitted to apply the
full range of sharia rules this does not
mean that they do not apply some Sharia
rules or teachings or that their
population and their rulers have
categorically rejected the Sharia in
stating that know Muslim land applies
the full range of sharia I am simply
stating a universally recognized fact as
for the statement that not applying the
Sharia makes one a catheter that is
simply what Allah says in the Quran
whoever does not judge by what Allah has
revealed then those are truly the
disbelievers now this is a clear-cut
verse that no muslim can deny but of
course that doesn't mean we can apply
this verse willy-nilly rather applying
this verse has many important nuances
that an unqualified person like me is
not in a position to exercise but my
point is I have never claimed that
whoever does not rule 100 by the Sharia
is automatically a cafe rather as I've
stated explicitly there are complex
contextual factors to take into account
which is why I have said explicitly on
many occasions leave the tech fear to
the qualified Scholars we're not going
to make Tech fear and say okay this
ruler is a cafe this ruler is a Catholic
uh people might have a problem the other
side doesn't have a problem with that as
well uh we'll just leave it like because
we're just we're lay people we're not
Scholars we have no Authority so there's
no reason for us to go to that extent
but we just affirm in no unclear terms
that if you're going to abolish the
sharing of Allah you're going to enforce
secularism you're going to put social
policies into place that are literally
taking Muslims out of Islam step by step
and destroying the next generation of
Muslims this is kofor this is kofor
we're going to be clear-cut about that
so one side will say oh you're Tech
Theory and the other side will say say
that oh well you're uh Moji you're
you're doing your job because you're not
going in specifically saying this is a
cafe this is
you know that's just my you know
understanding in a quick nutshell but
there's a lot of stuff I'll say like
Sajid apparently has missed all those
statements so hopefully he will take
note of what I'm saying in this video so
that he can stop misrepresenting me in
the future
now that we've debunked Sage's claims
let's move on to another major issue and
I invite you brother sagitt to have a
conversation about these issues let's
have a dialogue you have my number you
can contact me at any time and we can
easily set something up to openly
discuss these issues but if you're not
willing to discuss openly and prefer to
make a video response then I have some
questions that I insist that you address
I would really like to get your answers
to the following questions first if
criticism of rulers leads to Bloodshed
then why doesn't your history
criticizing U.S social policy and
criticizing U.S government officials
like ilhan Omar count as a security
threat number two if you're so concerned
about Bloodshed what about the Bloodshed
from two decades of the global war on
terror and cve policies that are applied
in Muslim countries these countering
violent extremism policies have been
used to kill and imprison countless
Muslims for opposing secular governance
on the basis that those Muslims are
dangerous hotages who should be
considered terrorists and extremists do
you have any concern for that Bloodshed
third there are around 50 or so Muslim
countries in the world do we have to
obey all 50 of those rulers and refrain
from criticizing any of them how is it
possible to do that when these countries
often disagree with each other and when
even the rulers of these countries are
engaged in criticizing other rulers of
other countries how should we decide
which rulers should be obeyed and which
ruler should not be criticized number
four here is a hypothetical if soldiers
came to a muslim's house under orders
from the ruler to sexually assault his
wife and murder his children if the
Muslim father says no don't do this to
my family does that count as an inciting
Rebellion number five imagine there is a
Muslim ruler who says I am a Muslim but
I'm going to force every Muslim in my
country to renounce Islam and become an
atheist is it permissible for Muslims to
publicly criticize the ruler for that
finally what do you have to say about
Sheikh al-bani and his public criticism
of Saudi is
Sheikh al-bani inciting Bloodshed I
would like Sajid and any other metralitu
answer these simple questions these are
questions no Muslims should have any
trouble answering it's only the bizarre
deviant ideology of the Mercedes that
complicate such simple obvious issues
may Allah Rectify our affairs